donald trump is nuts for the democrats
that's just an undisputed fact but it
seems like they feel he isn't the only
head of state who's lost a few of his
marbles
you alone possess the authority to order
the use of nuclear weapons
vesting one person with this authority
entails real risks
past presidents threatened to attack
other countries with nuclear weapons or
exhibited behavior that caused other
officials to express concern
about the president's judgment nearly 30
democrats signed that letter which
outlined four different ways to reduce
presidential power over the nuclear
button congressional oversight creating
a special counsel
consulting the speaker of the house why
the need for all these new rules if the
guy they say is bonkers
isn't in the white house anymore the
dems say they just don't want a repeat
of the past four years but some
republicans think the reason
is a bit more senile i mean cynical
sleepy joe wasn't just a political
nickname it appears to be a governing
strategy growing number of democrats who
are now concerned about giving joe biden
the codes for the nuclear system it's
not just republicans though
back in election season one poll said
most voters in a number of pivotal swing
states felt they had to choose between
two
old guys who were both mentally unfit
for the presidency
and judging by biden's campaign trail he
wasn't making things easy for himself
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created
by the go you know you know the thing no
man has a right to raise a hand to a
woman
in anger other than in self-defense and
that's
rarely ever occurs and so we have to
just change the culture
period and keep punching at it and
punching at it
and punching it it's my little sister
valerie and i'm jill's husband
oh no oh you switched on me so the
democrats might be scared with that guy
behind the nuclear button but it's not
much different than having biden at the
head of their expanding war agenda
the very same democrats for example are
saying america's longest war in
afghanistan
should be even longer to pull out within
several months now is a very challenging
and destabilizing efforts we've got to
be able to assure the world and the
american public that afghanistan will
not be a source of planning plotting to
project terrorist attacks
around the globe that's the minimum i'm
not sure we can do that without some
presence there
then there's this year's national
defense authorization act which the
democrats put forward to boost the
military budget to a total of around
740 billion dollars
today the house send a strong bipartisan
message to the american people
our service members and our national
security are more important than
politics
they're clearly not trying to put
forward some kind of pacifist agenda
so why should biden be at the head of
military operations but not have his
finger
on the nuclear button it could be
because mutually assured destruction
isn't fun for anyone but
when the killing is going on far away
anything goes
you